tyler glass now making his sixth start
of the season and we highlighted his
strikeouts dwayne 46 of them in 30 and
two-thirds and i think the most
impressive thing about all of that is
his pitches per inning oddly enough just
15 and a half pitches per inning
and he got him 99 up just above the zone
and no chance on that one no and you
know what whether that was glass now
zanino or it was both of them they read
the previous swing they saw the fastball
up over the bat he missed it by plenty
so they take it a little bit higher up
and he misses it by a little bit more
that swing just not able to get up near
that baseball
right by him
that takes care of loriano see what he
does here on three and one the pitch
swinging the ground ball sharply hip it
right into the shift and mike rosso and
short right he throws the first in time
and that will
retire the side so they get a hit but
that's it staring down the southpaw
swerve and cole irvin of the oakland a's
making his fifth start what a tremendous
job cole irvin has done taking advantage
of the opportunities in front of him
here's the pitch and that's right down
the middle ring him up strike three call
it good morning good afternoon good
night
there's a swing and a live drive to the
gap in right center field and that's
going to get down and go to the wall
over to go gather it in as loriano
margot is around first he's on his way
to second and he's going to pull in
there with a one-out double
and he got him swinging fastball up and
in
now one ball no strike in a world he's
got it picked off and he's going to run
at margot and now flips it to machine he
chased him toward third and chapman's
going to run him down in the baseline
and that's how the bottom of the first
comes to an end
and the pitch is a strike call
chapman
caught looking on a breaking ball three
strikeouts tonight that gives glass now
49 strikeouts 22 of those have come on
the curveball now which is tops in the
major leagues goes into the white of the
roof
yep
smokes one to right and it bounces off
the wall near the corner
tony kemp goes into
second base with a two out double
here's the one two fastball strike three
called he got him looking for the slider
and then just delivered about 99
and garcia had no chance two and two to
count to kiermeyer
now irvin again holds at the letters now
pitches home and there's strike three
call
so kk is out
and he hits this one well to center
l'oreal going back still going back and
he's got just enough room and he makes
the catch
and a good fastball suzuki fooled by it
and that'll do it we'll see what kind of
adjustments olson makes
ground ball right side sharply hit out
at second and out at first
and he pitches and he struck him out
swinging it took three pitches and never
saw a fastball the change up in two
sliders fans mitch moreland
phillips lines it up the right side
that's headed for the corner we could
watch him run
on his way to second the pick up by
brown
and phillips stops with the double
runner in scoring position let's see
what margot can do here comes the 2-0
and a change-up and that is rope toward
left but right at canna mark is there to
make the catch perfect positioning and
irvin survives a double
he's catching tonight here's the 1-0 fly
ball to center loriano comes in for it
and he makes the catch
loud sound off the bat
and a throw back to first base i guess
diaz was running and they're going to
double him off
it's tropicana field where anything and
everything is possible another last stop
back to the bump the one-two pitch
swinging in the midst of the ball down
in the dirt ceno knocks it down and
machines started to run to first base
and xenia said you know what i'll just
throw down there and it's going to beat
you
and that is strike three
you see a
half-hearted swing on that pitch
and cutting the miss he goes with a
breaking ball
strikes out canada on the curve
2-2 fastball outside corner swing and a
miss strikeout number five for urban
here's mike zanino zanino fly to le
field his first time 2-2
and a swing and a high fly ball left
center field lorianno going back looks
up and it is gone
off the c-ring in center field and mike
zenino has just given the raise a
one-nothing lead and that two-seamer
stayed up zenino got his arms extended
that's always dangerous
and boy that contact says it all and now
margot who has hit him hard twice once
for a hit
[Applause]
and a ground ball base head into right
phillips will score margot drives him
home a rosarenda goes to second another
raised lead two to nothing he's trying
to figure out tyler glass now his pitch
count is really manageable right now
into the dirt to swing and miss
[Applause]
down to first just at sugo to complete
the strikeout
chapman a strikeout and a fly ball to
right field and he smokes one to left
and that's gonna be a base hit big
bounce for margot
and they're gonna hold moreland at third
here's seth brown is over two
second and third two outs three two
class now delivers
and a little tap right side
thomas with a pickup and the flip to
first two men left by oakland they do
not score
and he gets the swinging strikeout up
yes so that is strikeout number six
for the halos
3-2 pitch
off the plate inside kiermeier swings
and misses
and a swing and a miss and cole irvin
strikes out the side in the sixth nicely
done
class now the front six has given up no
run nine
there's strikeouts cut and a miss
so kemp is out on strikes and then
strikeout number 10 tonight for tyler
glass now
that's a shot into center field
kiermeier angling back still on the red
he got it
and that's a great catch by kermer and a
tip of the cap there from his starting
pitcher tyler glass now
he throws 3-1
pumped in the air straightaway center
routine for caremeyer drifting over to
his lefty makes the catch to retire the
side and seven innings of five hit
shutout baseball for tyler glass now
another brilliant start with the runner
on and one out sean murphy's been
announced as the pinch hitter castillo
did get the save first pitch
bounced in the hole diving play
kicked off adamus's glove and
everybody's going to be safe
tony kemp due up for the a's
and uh swinging in a miss kemp out
number two and machine will be the
hitter
one two again ground ball first that's
picked up by diaz who makes the play
unassisted
and the rays win it